[Music]
and let's see who we can get hopefully
2100 is on deck
all right
so let's play an e4 let's go for the
quick kill here again sporebot one
and we're facing an alakan very very
nice
we're going to go for absolute maximum
here let's play the four pawns attack
d4
we've played the alakan with black in
the speedrun i don't remember us facing
it with white i think maybe we did once
or twice
boom
and after an ip6
the classical main line is e takes d6
and then black plays either cd or ed
i'm sure most people in the chat you've
probably seen like an alakan game or two
and you've seen that that how that goes
but why does a line which often flies
under the radar
and in my opinion it it might even be
the best way to fight for an advantage
it's also a very ambitious line and if
you don't know it well white can get
crushed in five moves because of how
ambitious it is
that's the four pawns attack that's the
move f4 supporting the e5 pawn
you're literally going for central
domination
but at the cost of development so we
fall behind in development which means
that we need to play very very carefully
not to
to make sure our center doesn't collapse
this is the first instance
where we have to be careful the
automatic move is knight f3
but it turns out that knight f3 is a
very serious inaccuracy because of
bishop g4
so
and the move c5 here would give up this
massive outpost on d5 we don't want to
create that gaping hole in the center
so instead we want to find a different
way to defend e4 and we do that with
bishop e3
generally black develops the bishop to
f5
and then we continue with knight c3
now now the threat is knight b4
so
we need to develop our knight so that
knight b4 can be met with rook c1 queen
d7 yeah that is one of the legitimate
lines
now at this point we've developed
several of our pieces so
it already makes sense to play knight f3
the move bishop g4 is no longer
dangerous
because we've developed enough pieces to
deal with to deal with that move so it's
time for us to complete our development
knight f3 bishop two castles
bishop g4 is played yeah that's a
legitimate move
and let me try to remember how we're
supposed to counter it
um
if i'm not mistaken
which i probably am we are supposed to
sacrifice upon here
yeah so there there there
yeah so i'm pretty sure we're supposed
to sack a pawn here for development
um
and play the move
bishop e2
bishop takes f3 bishop takes f3 and i
think we're supposed to give up that
pawn on c4 simply
and it turns out that our lead in
development and our two bishops
offer more than enough compensation for
it but but that could also be wrong
that could also be wrong
but we have to give it a shot this is
classic naredinsky style bishop b2
bishop f3 bishop f3
let him take it okay he doesn't take it
doesn't take it
okay now the situation again is changed
if we castle
then we allow bishop takes f3
bishop takes f3 knight takes d4 and this
d4 pawn we do not want to lose because
our center collapses if we lose that
pawn
um the move d5 comes to mind maybe we
should just push that pawn
but but then black plays bishop takes f3
and if we take back then we lose the e
pawn that's also not a pawn we want to
lose
it doesn't it's not entirely clear what
to do but that old move gain suggested
the move c5
it used to be the case that giving up
the d5 square was not worth it
but now the black has castled queen side
the move c5 essentially jumps jump
starts a queen side attack so i believe
that this is a theoretical move c5
we do give up the d5 score but in return
this pawn clamps down on black's
position
and our queen can later come out to a4
to start the attack
all right
so
no i still kind of remember this i think
this is this is all correct
so we take it
and
all right after queen takes d5
i believe
i think you did so
i believe that we can do several
different things we can probably just
castle
or we can play a move such as queen c2
yeah i should have looked this up at
some point because now i've gotten
dragged into theory that i don't know
very well
or we can play artemis style we can play
king f2
lending reinforcement to our bishop and
preparing queen a4 i actually quite like
that move
i like the move king f2 here
just to make sure the bishop is nicely
protected connecting our rooks
uh and then based on what he does we
will see if we can move the queen out
let's go king f2
or maybe get him out of his theory at
least
another idea is to go rook c1 followed
by bishop c4 we can also push the b pawn
try to create an attack that way
lots of possibilities here for white
lots of possibilities here for white
queen a4 is very very tempting but that
perhaps black goes queen e4
this guy's good
you know let's start with tickling him
let's go h3
see what he does
and based on that we're going to map out
our further course of action
the reason i want to go h3 is because if
bishop h5 at convenience like when i
went right i can play g4
and we want to have that move in our
pocket
anywhere with your pocket
all right
and then i want to play queen a4
bishop f5
a little bit unexpected i was expecting
bishop h5 but okay we'll take it
let's get this queen out onto the onto
the queen side
and our ultimate goal here is to play b4
b5 get this knight off of c6 and crash
through via a7
yeah maybe bishop b4 but i don't think
that's dangerous queen e4
yeah i thought this move was more
dangerous to the bishop on h5 now it
threatens bishop takes c5 that is the
immediate threat
why is that a threat because we cannot
take our queen will be hanging
um
there is a problem with b4 and that he
can play maybe knight takes d4
and try to sack the knight or the
exchange to open our king but i don't
think that's a big issue let's go before
i don't believe knight 64 is a big issue
here
very short position
we're trying to insist on
our plan here we're trying to go b5
and um
i think that maybe there was a stronger
move that
went a lot of material yeah
i kind of missed an idea that instead
would have i think yielded a huge
position
well i don't really understand it either
it's
it's sharp
yeah we missed the opportunity train on
that one but this queen is in big
trouble you know so the first thing i
see when i look at this position this
queen doesn't have a lot of squares
so training queens and playing b5 that
would probably be okay
but i feel like we could play for a
maximum by keeping the queens on the
board now can we even keep the queens on
the board if we wanted to
the answer is yes
can we keep the q how can we keep the
queens on the board
we can play
queen a3 now bishop b5 is the bishop is
pin plus he can still take our queen
all right
what exactly are we threatening here
well rook c1 is a possibility forcing
the queen back to e4 but we might want
to hold off on that move we might want
to try to get the e4 square under
control and then where kc1 would trap
the queen so there's a lot of
possibilities in a position like this
all right
how can we get the e4 squadron control
well we have a move like knight g5 in
certain cases
all right he goes back to goes bishop b7
how does that deal with b5 though i
don't get it because if we play b5 and
the knight has to drop back to b8 well
we're very happy to see
that five knight takes d4 maybe he once
takes bishop c5 i don't know b5 knight
d4 would just take i think
okay let's go b5
i don't really understand that move
and if knight b8 then i think we can
just grab that pawn on a7 because why
not
why can't we just grab that pawn
yeah he definitely missed this move
no doubt that black
oh we got subs black sword thank you
okay
might be
well give me that pawn please
the ship d3
i saw that move it's not as big of an
issue as it appears i think because we
can simply defend our bishop on d3
and we can do that by playing rook h to
e1
okay
this is tremendously complex and at this
level these kind of kinds of games just
kind of happen and
you just gotta roll with it and and you
gotta
gotta try to make the most out of the
chaos thank you for the tier two
now we've got several good moves here i
think
um
you could try to get rid of this queen
but amazingly he's found a great
resource for kc1 then queen a4 and the
queen simultaneously defends the bishop
and offers a queen trade
so better idea probably is to go rook a
b1
better oh but then he takes and we take
okay the rook ab1 is probably a better
idea we'll have to speed up a little bit
all right
bishop c6 will play rook ec1
and try to get rid of the queen queen a4
anyway wow
brilliant
absolutely brilliant yeah we have to
take i missed this move
the sun game is not worse for us i guess
but now we have to go into an end game
let's go knight d2 let's try to get this
knight around to c4 and a5
okay
i definitely would rather have white
here because this pawn on b7 is a long
term weakness
the file is open
if we can get our knight to a5
then we're in pretty decent shape
let's go knight c4 why not
if he takes on e5 we take back with a
knight
so we simultaneously prepare to swing
the knight to a5 and defend the pawn on
e5 definitely i didn't play this right
i i'm sure i think i saw the winning
move
and i only saw it after we made a
different move so
it's part of it you got to adapt to the
new set of circumstances
bishop c6
okay knight a5 is no longer effective
because we give up the e5 pawn we don't
want our center to collapse
we do not want our center to collapse
here
so one option is to target this bishop
and offer a bishop trade
why is offering a bishop trade
potentially good for us because
well because then the b7 pawn is going
to be left without a defender
okay takes we take with the knight
now i think that might have been a
mistake the e6 pawn is quite quite weak
rook a hf8
all right
well
i kind of want to get out of this pin
let's go king g3 let's get out of the
pin
yeah very strong player so we're going
to have to speed up we're going to take
with the knight to not ruin the
integrity of our pawn structure i don't
want to play gf and get isolated pawns
even if it means dropping the knight
from the outpost
one positive byproduct of this is the
rook is exiting the e6 pawn
so let's drop our bishop back here
and try to mount the pressure on that
pawn and as a follow-up we could try to
double rooks on the e-file and keep
targeting it
yeah this is very this is about equal i
think this is not
if it's better for for me then it's only
a tiny advantage
so it's going to be it's going to be a
grind here winning this with two minutes
yeah so far i have not lost the game in
the 10-minute speed run i think
okay we're going to double rooks
and this king on g3 is a little bit in
the way so let's move it back to h2
in order to be able to move this bishop
along the diagonal we could also play
bishop g3
and reposition the bishop on a slightly
more active square on f2 it's not really
doing anything we don't need another
pair of eyes on the d4 pawn our knight
and the rook are perfectly doing the job
no it doesn't hang d4 we have two
defenders on it
okay
g3
probably going to go g5 is this guy
okay let's go bishop b5 offer up a trade
and try to get this rook off of f6
okay he goes for it
now we get a very nice knight on e5
plus the king has to move from d7 which
which would mean that the e6 pawn
becomes a lot weaker
can we ex how can we exploit the
weakness of the e6 pawn in this position
or how can we try we can go knight back
to g4 attack the rook
prepare to capture on e6
now things get a little bit iffy for
black
but if he goes rook g6 then it
complicates the scenario because if we
take on e6
then black takes and he takes on d4
and i'm not convinced that that position
is so clear
i'm thinking we should play a little bit
more patiently
what does that mean well
move such as rook f1 could be nice here
occupying the open file which was
vacated by black's rook continuing to
poke and pride and
eventually try to find ways to make
inroads into black's position such as
rook f7 that's how you play these end
games
okay night at 95 he's got rook f6 which
i don't want to allow so let's drop it
back to e3 with tempo
after rook d7 we cannot play rook f7 due
to bishop d6 check
what we can do perhaps is reposition the
rook back to b1
and go for that old plan of attacking
the b7 pawn
trying to
eventually overextend him
okay knight c4 makes sense
yeah let's go knight c4 try to go to e5
if bishop f6 then we get we take e5 ah
we take e6 i think
g4
and finally a blunder what is the fork
eventually we put pressure pressure
pressure and oftentimes if if you do it
well enough a blunder does come
um we got lucky here but
often oftentimes these kinds of blunders
are the results of
are are the results of this kind of
pressure that we put on our opponent
all right
nice magnus carlson tv
well i think he missed the fork because
he thought we wanted to go knight a5
one source of blunders that people
almost never talk about is you're like
well how did he blunder this obvious
move well to you it was obvious why you
played your last move but your opponent
might have
misinterpreted
the reason behind your last move you
might you might have thought the knight
comes to a5 and you might have been
convinced of
that all right so we can grab another
pawn but i don't really want to allow
the rook to get active
so what i'm going to do instead is rook
f1 offer the rook trade force the rook
off of the f file
and then infiltrate via the f file to f7
or f3 or whatever
let's go rook f7 seventh rank
perhaps we could drop it to h7 go after
the h1
yes
this guy does not go gentle into that
good night
okay now i don't want the rook to come
to f6 and then f2 that's a scenario we
want to avoid
which is why i'm going to go rook f4
let's delegate
give the other broken assignment here
and potentially piggies on the seventh
which is the ideal
placement of rooks on the seventh rank
of the end game
we can go for it even though he's got
bishop e3 bishop takes d4 we could give
up that pawn because we have rooks on
the seventh rank
if we want to be we want to play like a
russian schoolboy you want to eliminate
all sorts of counter play
but if he goes bishop f6 we might have
to we might have to give that pawn up
and suck it up yeah
we're gonna have to suck it up and go
work f7
which is totally winning because this is
just one pawn we take on c7
we take on c7 and we threaten checkmate
on c8 he's got a couple of checks but
not more than that
okay rook f6 generally in such endgames
you wanna you wanna get the king as as
far into the center as possible you
don't want the king stumbling around
and getting into a mating net so we just
go king e2
yeah king e1 would be worse i'm trying
to get the king to the center so that we
don't have to worry about random
mating nets and okay let's see it as me
tough game and we're over 2100 less than
100 points away from the conclusion
very very nice
game even though there were a lot of
mistakes i'm not gonna pretend that i
played well
i think
closer to the start of the game i missed
an opportunity to put him away
so let me talk about where this
opportunity was i think here
there was a hidden way after queen a4
queen e4
for some reason i completely missed a
relatively obvious move
and i don't know why i missed it it's
weird
um i'm not sure why i missed this move
let me let me just show you guys i'm
gonna have to run right after i show you
this one moment because i don't want to
miss
uber
yep so after queen e4 we simply have
knight g5 i i saw the the presence of
this move but i thought black had a
check
and i simply didn't calculate far enough
after g3 black is busted he's gotta move
his queen we take the pawn we win a lot
of material
after queen back to d5
you know we can take on f7 but even
better is to play something like bishop
f3
and then pawn up to b4 and the attack is
totally unstoppable here against black's
king
so this was relatively straightforward i
don't know why i didn't do it but the
fact remains
[Music]